this is Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist and I got
with me my coach Chuck nice Daniel
tweeting at Chuck nice comic well thank
you sir yes I follow you I follow you
too to the ends of the earth
where are you only follow me on Twitter
I'm following you to the gates of hell
you're following me like like this maybe
I will
earth has no ends it's a continuous
surface in case you hadn't noticed
see that's why I followed this program
this particular episode we're going to
talk about the roots of mental toughness
as they resided inside the former
national security advisor to the
President of the United States Susan
Rice and since we're talking about
mental toughness yes we need we need our
we need a line I'm the person whose
mental I'm welcome your go-to mental
person I'm happy to be the mental person
of this group right and you're one of
our featured people on Startalk
all-stars it's just great to have you in
the Startalk family I'm happy to be as
long as we don't we're not a pain always
reaching for you for this but just
always good to have you just a little
bit of background on Susan Rice she came
out with a book called tough love tough
love and she was national security
advisor to President Obama
yes he's as of 13 2017 so a UN
ambassador mm-hmm so the United States
has an ambassador to the UN as distinct
from ambassadors to other countries of
the world right and she was a Rhodes
Scholar Wow
and so she went to new college at Oxford
and she's authored them a more tough
love my story of the things worth
fighting for
interesting yeah so she's she's she's
got the pedigree she got the attitude
she's got the you know she's ready to
he's ready to rock shake shake shake
that up mhm and so she credits some of
what she's accomplished I would say a
lot of what she's accomplished to how
she was raised with tough love tough
love let's check out that first clip
tough love
kind of title like we say of our
grandparents so you're not a grandparent
yet god no okay so what are you up their
name in a book like what the grant cuz
grant it's that's a previous generations
are you dogging my title up a little bit
come on do you know what everybody I
know knows what tough love me they do
the young people know even the young
people hell yeah okay cuz certainly my
young people no no no the young P and
all the young people who work with me
know what it means to because I last
time I saw their upbringing they get a
trophy for participating there's nothing
tough about their household that's the
point so to me it means loving fiercely
but not uncritically and you know when
you mess up the people who love you
supposed to tell you straight up you
know that your stuff is not together I
think that's the polite term and there
are many families where there are always
bolstering each other's efforts even if
it has failed and you're saying if
someone is found you get on there can
you tell them how and why with the aim
of helping them do better do bad just to
beat them right right right right right
but I'm just contrasting it with the
fear of telling being truthful with
someone because you might hurt their
feelings yeah we that was not a familiar
concept so my parents raised me and my
brother very much in the vein of tough
love and my for better or for worse my
own kids well they they seemed to be
doing okay so one's a senior in college
and one's a junior in high school okay
so then you're doing okay so far yes
yeah so guys what do you think of her
definition of tough love I mean I think
it's a unique definition and what we
normally think of at least in the field
of Psychiatry is tough love is you know
when somebody is kind of really out of
control or they're let's say a drug
addict and it's about I mean literally
out of control like out of control their
own lives
yeah and it's about then coming in with
harsh enforcement's of restriction
so you know it's not what she said does
she have well I mean she they're
different types of parenting's are there
three different types of parenting one
is authoritative authoritative one is
authoritarian and the other is
permissive right so she's more just what
I think she's describing is
authoritative parenting which is that
you're demanding you have high
expectations waffles lots of structure
lots of structure but you're also
responsive and like connected
emotionally whereas authoritarian do
what I say that's it there's no you know
so but so so her way which is not an
authority not authority not dictatorial
right like to tell rotative yes why
should we assume that would work for
everyone wouldn't that just fall flat
for some people trying to grow up boom
and see that's where when you said how
do you feel about her and I said I would
have but my response was going to be
it's fraught and the reason why I think
it's fraught is because children are
individuals who respond differently
differently to different stimuli so I'm
asking Heather right right so there's
that show yeah so basically it's all
about the combination of the personality
type of the child with the type
parenting so there's no one right way to
parent and every type of parenting
there's articles that say that it's
really good or it's really bad and
really the key factor is how it enter
relates with the personality and it's
the same thing with learning like for
example some people need really
restrictive ways to learn like being
tested all the time and having structure
and they work really well not system
others don't and they need a more sort
of permissive environment where they can
learn on their own so this right here is
there was one way everybody got raised
right no I that works for you or it
doesn't right and so in some cases
depending and also call their cultural
differences as well so you know
depending on what the Coleman is it some
people go
[Music]
did your culture go like for example
authoritarian or like sort of I'm very
very restrictive parenting works better
in Asian cultures because that's part of
the culture they find that that type of
parenting whereas in the US for example
they get worse results with that kind of
parenting because it links with the
culture yeah exactly so you have to be
careful when you're imposing other sort
of cultural standards that work in one
place here it might however you know
sometimes it's it's when you look at
cultural no I will just say this and
people are going to be maybe probably
want to be heard but the more what is
perceived to be permissive in many
cultures are the way Caucasian parents
white people actually let their children
do pretty much anything but I see that
there are some benefits to that where
the child feels emboldened to try things
and be more adventurous so you know
there's so the permissive type of
parenting has its own advantages so it
does encourage independence the idea is
that you sort of create an environment
where the child can make their own
decisions and that they'll be more
prepared for life but on those kinds of
parenting you get you get more people
tend to be more impulsive yet at the end
of the day they are better when it comes
to sort of making their own decisions
and and so you know every as I said
every type of parenting has pluses and
minuses yeah so when kids are born there
should be some little readout on what
kind of upbringing they that that
genetic eventually okay this one needs
you know oh they are going to be beating
your ass ever
let me tell you something mister your
backsides in for a real tanning film
called three identical strangers Wendy's
triplets in her documentary
and they were separated at birth and it
was an experiment that was obviously
this should never be done but they did
this where they an experiment where none
of the parents knew none of the parents
or the children knew what was happening
so the same exact DNA but they put them
in three different households with
different socio-economic statuses
different types of parenting this is
legal this was not legal people do the
most physicists will do is give you a
nuclear bomb what was interesting and
low socio-economic yeah but they also
had different types of parenting and I
think it was like the lower SES or you
know is more permissive socioeconomic
status had the highest one I think was
very distant cold and restrictive and I
believe that child ended up committing
suicide yeah yeah black people have
suicide rate so she also credits her
ability to tackle difficult situations
to playing sports
oh so there's a whole social thing that
goes on in sports it's not just the
contest itself but the interpersonal
dimension of it let's find out what she
says about this
I was very much a tomboy growing up and
I was really into sports and my idea of
fun as a scrappy kid was playing you
know football with the boys or
basketball on the neighborhood court but
that evolved into playing varsity
basketball as well as varsity tennis a
little bit of softball in high school
and I was a much better tennis player I
and I am a much better tennis player
than I ever was a basketball player
there's there are a lot of myths out
there about me the only good one is that
I was a really excellent basketball
player so people want to believe you
were good at basket people have
circulated a myth that I was a great
basketball player but in fact not true
in fact in fact I was a mediocre
basketball player and a pretty good
tennis player cool okay and still play
time so what did it do for you other
than that you taught me it taught me how
to really compete and to lose but also
to win and to want to win and to lead a
team and I spent a lot of time
describing the role of that I had as
national security advisor as being akin
to playing point guard on basketball
team because one that was my position
too when I was playing in high school
and later in graduate school is the
captain usually a point guard not
necessary thing cabal just wondering all
right I mean but on the court that's in
fact often the role that the point
guards playing because they're seeing
the whole court they're calling the
plays or they're dishing the ball for
the most part to the putting the ball in
motion yeah and and you know making sure
that the the stars who usually those
with the great outside shots are the
ones you know under the basket er
putting get the opportunity now then
they get your you know your yours
extraordinary point guards who do all of
the above I was not one of those and so
it was really a huge growth experience
playing both tennis and basketball
here's what I wonder are is is the
personality type that we see among sort
of athletes it is did that develop by
them being athletes or did it was it
always there
and now it attaches to the fact that
they have great athletic performance
yeah I mean it's like what came first
the chicken or the egg I think certain
types of people it was just laid by a
bird that was not a chicken
okay yeah and there's a mutation and
then what comes out of the egg is what
you would call a chicken first chicken
got it so a cow a to me you know certain
people with personnel you're born with
the genetic predisposition have certain
types of personality traits and those
might be more attracted to certain types
of sports also you know so it could be
that you are more into playing with a
group and a team and you know you like
that aspect you must know what
personality attracts to golf mental
discipline though it takes like you know
just to play golf even or you know any
sports super mentally tough absolutely
and so you need that so I think you come
to it those at least to excel in sports
come to it with certain genetic
predisposition and then they develop it
even further so I think it's the
discipline it's being able to control
your emotions under pressure high stakes
that's another nice control over your
body no it's mostly control over your
minds because baseball isn't 90 percent
of baseball is half mental right but
yeah I mean it's being able to have the
discipline to practice but also to
control your emotions under high stress
to rebound from losses right you know so
if something happens you lose a point
you get an out you have to be able to
get right back on there and not be kind
of which rules all good life skills so I
think you know you you're attracted to a
sport for certain reasons but then you
develop these skills along the way okay
so but without sports you still want to
be mentally tough what would be what's a
what's a pathway if you didn't do sports
like Susan did what's interesting is
that you can actually when we talk about
mental toughness we're talking about
when you're sort of emotionally aroused
or have a negative emotion how you can
kind of in a way suppress it and keep
going on
let it kind of defeat you and so we
studies have shown that actually
mindfulness and meditation increases
parts of this particularly the left
prefrontal cortex which works to down
regulate the amygdala and so those
people who can sort of sort of overcome
trauma big delay as a part of your brain
it's part of being involved in emotion
idle flight fight or flight response and
so it's resilience or mental toughness
is really about how we can overcome
these negative emotions and go on and
sort of reframe things in a positive way
and we find that if you have more
activation in the left prefrontal cortex
you can do that one way to do that is
through meditation so what if just as a
question like for developing mental
toughness
what if adversity and failure actually
so of course everybody feels bad and
their anger right but what if that is
actually fuels better performance what
so what I'm saying is that which doesn't
kill you makes you stronger right that
makes you like you know so there's
there's a sort of optimal need a little
bit of stress that actually helps us
increase our performance and there's no
sort of inoculation a little bit you
know so it's all about the amount so a
little bit will get you to the sort of
we call optimal state of arousal and
increase and improve your performance
too much however physiologic physiologic
stimulation stimulation exactly so you
need really really like this game buddy
if I'm a track buddy of my father my
father ran track he they were competing
against the New York Athletic Club okay
all white all wasp of the day right and
he was no geez now I'm not exactly in
the in his Club Pioneer Club
they picked up everyone who has not
admitted to the New York Athletic Club
whose reflects and Jews it's my father
ran alongside Jews apparently not anyone
from your family now right so there's
still a racial dimension to this as the
West is so much in society back then it
was deep deeper than even today right as
much as anyone complains it was worse it
only encompassed everything okay so so
they're coming around the back stretch
my guys name is Johnny
is ahead of the the runner from the New
York Athletic Club and on the
backstretch for the final straightaway
the guy from the New York Athletic Club
Johnny Johnson overhears him yelled to
his runner catch that [ __ ] oh wow
right which by the way is shocking today
but back then and so he said this is one
[ __ ] he ain't gonna catch increased
motivation exactly so so too little is
not good just enough words right but if
he let's say got really angered by that
to the point where he was so enraged
that he kind of his performance could
have to subtract yeah too much just
enough yeah so you grew up in a Jewish
household yes I did so what's up squirt
therefore I did not play it's just not
really true that scene and the movie
airplane where the flight attendant then
stewardess was had reading material and
someone seated there says I just need
something light and said well here's a
pamphlet on famous Jewish athletes okay
very important there's exceptions but
you know in general yeah the stereotype
is is legit I was never very good ya
know not you know what I known this
before this episode let both your asses
out in the street how are they doing no
I did I played several sports and and
but I didn't like it because I was
forced into playing sports because my
father was a really accomplished athlete
another way to say it is you didn't have
the mental toughness that's right well
oh you were like wrestling I used to
wrestle a road yeah and I play
basketball street ball in the Bronx
hmm and here's the measure of things
just so you know if it's if it's a
five-on-five choosing sides how we're in
that ranking are you chosen oh I was
always first first yeah okay no I was
never first but I was like fifth so I
was like midway in the Bronx but then I
spent a year up in Lexington
Massachusetts and I went to the
playground there and we played ball and
I went to jump to block someone shot and
I blocked it with my elbow and I
realized I jumped much higher than was
necessary to block this person shot
because my elbow blocked the ball right
so they all thought I was some amazing
basketball player turns out you were
just black funny how that that sounds
like we need to go to come earth coming
back more with my interview with former
national security adviser to to Barack
Obama Susan Rice we've got a new book
tough love and we'll just explore
unpacking the tough love and how all
that came about and we'll talk more
about that when Startalk returns welcome
back to you star talk Chuck nice yes sir
Heather Berlin have a give me your full
title cuz when he first came on I didn't
I'm a neuroscientist an assistant
professor of psychiatry at the Icahn
School of Medicine at Mount Sinai
see that's why so my interview with
Susan Rice former national security
advisor to the president what we're
talking about tough mental toughness a
running theme in her book tough love
but in there is also just how do you
deal with stress mental toughness is one
thing just come back from failure but
how about just stress yeah how about you
know if you try to keep peace in the
world there's no greater source of
stress than geopolitics the Obama
administration like so many was not
short on crises so I just asked her what
were your challenges
in that row let's check it out so I
think the hardest part of the job of
National Security Adviser is the number
and the weight of the issues that you're
confronting at any given time I mean
it's it's almost overwhelming
it feels I describe it as like a slab of
concrete lying on your chest and then
they just put more and more bricks on it
and you still got to breathe so for
example in my first six months on the
job this is beginning in June July 1st
of 2013 the day I got in the office the
Egypt blew up and a coup occurred which
we didn't actually term a coup it was
the Arab Spring this was after the Arab
Spring but but yeah in then Edward
Snowden was in the middle of doing his
nasty releasing you know alleged US
government secrets we had the war in
Syria evolved into the the use of
chemical weapons and the challenge over
the red line that President Obama drew
as to whether or not we'd deal with the
chemical weapons through the use of
force we had you know a extraordinary
secret negotiation going on that led to
the Iran deal we had secret negotiations
going on it led to the opening to Cuba
we just had all these things with day
one first six months but day one was
Egypt and and you know and that's not
even giving you the whole picture of you
know what we were dealing with but the
crush of those issues and the import of
each of them and if you know the the the
downside of failure for our security and
our interests on any given one of those
was quite daunting so had what kind of
people handle stress better than others
well there's actually been some studies
which find that there are some genetic
differences so we all have it's adaptive
to have a stress response so you have
it's you know what's called the HPA axis
but you know that fight-or-flight
response gives you such pH stands for
what
the hypothalamic adrenal no no pituitary
adrenal axis so basically it's releasing
norepinephrine and epinephrine and then
also you have cortisol so that kind of
gets you going when you have to run or
fight something and we all have that and
that's adaptive but then what comes in
next is how do you handle it how do you
go back I got it yeah before you
continue uh-huh so the idea that when
you're scared you pee your pants right
okay is that from Birds bird if you if
you scare bird a bird poops and then
flies off great right so they don't want
to carry extra weight but actually no
it's the reverse so when the sympathetic
nervous system is aroused we actually it
restrict so you become less likely to
basically crap your path everyone talk
about poop in your pants that's
interesting I don't know where that came
from but physiologically speaking that
signs up and stays up it stays in it's
not the time to be doing your business
what you gotta run help if you were a
little later silly crap your pants
because I don't want to do anything with
you oh that might be a way to get the
animal to run away from you yeah I see I
see so you have this response everything
sort of restricts and but then the
parasympathetic nervous system kind of
kicks in which kind of relaxes
everything and calms it down and that's
how people respond or deal with stress
so genetically speaking some people or
more what we call resilient they can
respond to stress and and kind of calm
down their nervous system can this be
trained so with certain techniques
behavioral techniques we call it it's a
biopsychosocial kind of phenomena where
there's some biological aspects there's
some things in your environment that can
help you um but I guess me yeah tighten
that question a does more exposure to
stress make you better at stress the
next time what does it make you worse
there's a theory that it's called about
inoculation so in small doses so that
the whole thing there's this actually a
great book all the coddling of the
American mind about how you know we're
protecting our kids so much yes exactly
Jonathan hight and it's safe spaces
Gregg lukianov
and basically you know we're creating
these safe spaces we're protecting our
kids we're trying to allow them to have
any anxiety but actually it's good to
have it in small amounts to have a
little bit of diversity adversity
reminded safe spaces are you were warned
in advance that someone might say
something that would trigger you yeah
exactly and then so you avoid it exactly
okay which is not really good
psychologically speaking what we want to
do actually to decrease anxiety is
called exposure the more you expose
people you can train the brain and the
body how to respond and so then when
something let's say really traumatic
happens you'll be more prepared to
handle that so in small doses that could
help you but in large doses it could
really it could hinder you and we also
find that like especially during youth
in childhood if you're exposed to high
cortisol levels it actually affects the
way the hippocampus the part of the main
involved in memory develops but we find
that to people who are traumatized early
in life have smaller hippocampus but in
later in life you can actually try to
regrow those neurons and exercise
aerobic exercise hi is plural of
hippocampus yes okay I can't buy it Mary
yes that hurt my prefrontal cortex so I
had to ask Susan how did she cope with
the stress let's ask her let's find out
the other challenge was how do you not
just deal with all the crises in your
inbox but how do you also as I say in
the book put points on the board get
affirmative things done that we chose to
do that we thought would be beneficial
to the United States so for example like
negotiating the Paris climate agreement
we didn't have to do that
but we chose to do it that was an
affirmative but you want your job to be
more than just solving problems you want
to actually be proactive right and be
remembered for doing something
progressive or positive exactly right so
those were the two big challenges and
then in terms of my background and what
prepared me I mean first of all I was
fortunate to have had a series of jobs
in the run-up to becoming national
security advisor that had given me a
real insight into
the work and the the the you know the
issues and how to how to navigate but I
also had learned as a child something
that I found was really invaluable as
national security adviser which is to be
able to compartmentalize you know the
painful tough wrenching issues that you
got to deal with from you know when you
come home and try to be a mom or a or a
wife or whatever it is and not let the
weight of those issues
literally prevent you from sleeping
exercising functioning oh my god you
know it wasn't just a bad day at the
office a bad day on planet earth you
know you learned some stuff in that job
that you really wish you didn't know
that day in the Western Hemisphere right
so I actually learned that as I as I
explained through enduring my parents
really ugly and in violent divorce and
yet still trying to you know perform in
school and you know be a good student
play on my sports teams and try to
maintain my friendships that you know
focus on what you have the ability to
control and don't let that which you
can't completely control [ __ ] you
emotionally or psychologically because I
wonder hassle my most creative thoughts
come when things kind of slip in a
spillage from one thing to another so
it's a possible to overcome part
mentally yeah I know first of all it is
an adaptive defense mechanism because
you know things are stressful and
overwhelming but you still have to
function in society or you got to eat
right you can kind of suppress well it's
one technique is to suppress or repress
things to the unconscious but core
mentalizing is you sort of put it in
different brain state you only can
access it when you're one state and not
the other which temporarily works but we
see psychiatric illnesses where in a
sense they're over compartmentalizing
and if they actually split into these
different it used to be called multiple
personality disorder but they basically
the idea is that you now start forming a
whole nother identity that's associated
with those traumatic thoughts that's the
limiting case of this right and then you
can't access and can only access them
when you're in one state and not the
other so they become sort of almost so
separate that the information flow isn't
there anymore
and you kind of dissociate is what we
call it so suit of identity disorder
though there you go yeah so what is what
are ways people learn to cope with
difficult situations when they have to
function in the rest of their lives is
it's compartmentalizing the only way or
is there some oh so there are a number
of defense mechanisms and we all kind of
tend toward one of the other like for
example people who are highly
intelligent you use intellectualization
as a defense mechanism right I can't
imagine who that might be but you can
kind of explore over intellectualize but
but that's a more mature defense
mechanism so there's more mature ones
and there's more primitive ones are less
sophisticated so they'll be just like
where you automatically repress
something or relegate it to the
unconscious um where it can then come up
in other ways right you can percolate
uninvited uninvited exactly so then you
know these classic cases with like Freud
describes if the psychosomatic symptoms
all of a sudden you have some weird
twitch in your arm or you know comes out
in other ways so I think they're they're
more adaptive types of defense
mechanisms um and they're ones that can
be more problematic but they all taken
to the extreme can become problematic
and create psychiatric illness the idea
I mean the real goal is to integrate the
uncomfortable memories and anxiety
provoking thoughts into your
consciousness in a sort of neutral way
where it doesn't disturb your daily you
just raised a point yeah if you have a
really uncomfortable memory mm-hmm
why not suppress it because it will come
out in other ways my suppresses so
effectively yeah it'll never come out
maybe for years and years and years and
then ten years later all of a sudden you
have like some users panic attack
because you were triggered by something
that was like deep in your unconscious
so the best idea is to reintegrate that
memory in a neutral way so it doesn't
work so it doesn't lurk in the
background doing weird things and affect
your behavior outside of your awareness
okay so you want leaders to be able to
to be able to not have something lurk
right sounds like a good thing
not to have lurking leaders God what is
that sounds so good where we gonna get
lurking inside into your own unconscious
processes is really not great so you
know just being sort of ignorant and
blind to them is not a good policy but
we got to take a break but when we come
back we'll get into the anatomy hard for
terrorists
we're back start talking in this segment
we're gonna talk about the future of
national security featuring my interview
with Susan Wright's former national
security advisor to Barack Obama and
since we're talking about security we
bringing somebody would ask what he does
for a living
Steven Steven Garcia welcome thank you
for Startalk it is and your kind of
local to us yeah so we're gonna pull you
back yeah totally pull you back but I'm
definitely a fan of the podcast
excellent so your expert on data and
cybersecurity chief information security
officer at consensus very cool company
name what is a change watch excuse me
yes yeah blockchain software tech
company very nice an advisory board
member for Rutgers University's big data
program this so Big Daddy Big Data
that's what he put on his business card
so let's go hit the Susan interview and
then we'll come right back to you
do you have a sense of the direction of
the future of security national security
you know is it how many soldiers you
have lined up on a battlefield or is it
how many programmers you have to protect
your your cyberspace or is it how many
scientists and engineers you have to
innovate I mean so the the the profile
of war is evolving yes so what do you
see the future if you had a crystal ball
given your life experience well I'm I
hate traffic and crystal balls didn't
take physics but I would I would say
several things one the domains in which
conflict can occur or evolving so and we
think of fighting as being on a on the
ground or in the air or on the sea but
it's also increasingly as we discussed a
little bit earlier in space undersea in
the cyber domain and and elsewhere that
are very hard for the average
American to envision and all those
domains are already active battle spaces
at least in theory but then they're the
battle space is yet to be right so then
so they're there those are the physical
domains then there's the means of combat
potentially and that's where things like
artificial intelligence machine learning
data you know biotech and and you know
CRISPR come in because all of these are
ways in which the nature of the tools
that we have to engage in combat
potentially can change radically and
then the question becomes such moral
issues as ones of agency like do we ever
want to have fully autonomous weapons
what happens when an artificial
intelligence outsmarts the people who
built these weapons in the first place
yeah so what what kind of security risk
do we face today as a country cyber
security yes and what should we do about
it I mean to start based on what's who's
to say I think I think we don't want
autonomous weapons right you every major
sci-fi movie we've seen is talked about
right 2001 a Space Odyssey Tron all the
Matrix movies Terminator 1 Terminator 2
Judgment Day this is known we just kind
of can't let that happen
we just went right we just want ordinary
people giving the command to kill rather
than machines giving the command to kill
[Laughter]
wants to drop bombs I think I got a
chance to reason with him versus a
machine unless the machine has a higher
level of reasoning than you do
[Laughter]
that's the point where the machines say
humans are no longer useful survival of
this world exactly I mean we do tend to
make irrational decisions which can be
good and bad right but I mean we have
empathy so that's but but sometimes we
might choose in terms of numbers to kill
more people because of an emotional
decision versus a rational one yeah so
but why wouldn't a I also have those
same emotional profiles in principle if
they like us except better versions
because they don't actually feel emotion
we can program in an algorithm but the
actual feeling of say you know sadness
or pain or empathy I don't think that
they will ever have that how do we know
we didn't that wasn't just programmed
into you because I have subjective
experience I think therefore I am I feel
what should we be doing
what's up sever point - right we have
new theatres of war right see right your
boy Bill Nye he's on a show called blind
spot where they did a whole episode on
some hackers taking over a satellite
that was weaponized right and you know
back in the Reagan time when we talked
about Star Wars it felt like sci-fi and
it was out of the realm of possibility
we're now maybe not so much most of the
world's data travels just be clear Star
Wars under Reagan because most people
alive today yeah we're not yet born when
Reagan was present enough you're not
referring to the movie series no no your
first ever been program prophesy the the
four of monies to create a fail-safe
foolproof defense system yeah to then
render the Soviets
weaponry absolutely absolutely okay but
it doesn't need to just remain defensive
it can be offensive right and so with
this new age space race with satellites
going up into space that's another
theater the undersea water cable was
getting tapped for information that
could be another big source of national
security so we're gonna be moving away
from marching armies to defense of
cyberspace yeah and it makes more as a
future war yeah it makes more sense
because the risk to reward ratio is
better right there's a value on human
life versus data right so if you can
still take over a country with a few
keystrokes
versus a standing army makes a little
bit more sense on multiple sounds like
ease
sound like okay what's in your basement
dude here's how you do that you just
it also gives lesser powers the
opportunity to enter the theater of war
yeah as opposed to our you know more
commonly known enemies yeah
it democratizes who can start a war is
it right yes yeah the playing field does
change a little right because you don't
need that capital for tanks planes okay
as creepy and as weird as it is that we
could be cyber attacked that's just
another way to be attacked yeah so I'd
be otherwise we spending money on tanks
spend the money on cyber protection and
you don't see any problem at that not
when he owns the Department of Homeland
Security they do have the cyber security
and infrastructure security agency and
they are responsible for you know
protecting our federal networks and
there's a few pillars of things that
they do protect on a national level but
I think it's important to to to not just
think about this in terms of
nation-states we also have to think
about this in terms of private companies
because the internet doesn't
discriminate with whether I come into
you as a private individual to make my
way to government right so it has to be
a partnership right because all
governments use third parties anyway
right so if you're X Y Z random company
that has government contracts your
potential vector well I asked you in
what countries needed to do going
forward to change their approach to
national security issues let's check it
out so should the future of those
meetings that you described with these
heads of agency should they have an
ethicist sitting right at the same table
because your body that's the health and
right now we have lawyers maybe we
should have lawyers and that that says
did I say lawyers each of us actually
have to be emphasis not just have a
specialized somebody to police us
because we don't think about the
consequences everybody should be
thinking about absolutely I was not
taught in school no and in the other
problem your mama give it to you but
otherwise don't exactly and the ethics
that we may apply to the
questions of war and peace are not gonna
be the same ethics at other countries
apply and how do you therefore have
global norms and rules about how to deal
with these new tech try that with the
Geneva Convention and in to a large
extent that worked mm-hmm
but you know it's in its you can observe
and in police and in force you know
those kinds of crimes it's a lot harder
to see how you police and enforce you
know what you've taught a machine to do
particulars is out of your control or
cyber attacker or disinformation or just
weeks into it absolutely I mean so it's
getting wild out there informations
getting weaponized yes absolutely
and what it was exactly what we've seen
with respect to how Russia is trying to
corrupt our democracy and pet Americans
against each other not just working it
they're effective at it and it will work
unless we are get hip to it and work
together to prevent it but you know
information is definitely being
weaponized by domestic actors and
foreign actors and we need to find new
ways to both you know determine the
quality of information and not allow the
weapons to be turned against our unity
and democracy this is part of the cost
of an open free society which we have
susceptibilities that closed societies
don't have that's exactly right and
that's an eternal battle
let's hope it's an eternal battle
because otherwise we lose I'm gonna look
at our susceptibilities as banking
there's interpersonal there's how people
are treating each other
there's elections yeah all of this has a
cyber component to it because we now
interact through our Facebook pages and
and we see ads or videos so how do you
how do you balance the free movement of
people through society with security
risk that we face walking into it
flat-footed
yeah well delegate
no I like every tool double-edged right
so we're an open and free society and we
want that but there are risks to that
right and so in particular attention
with our elections I point to a
microwave Goff has a book called the
Russian Roulette but it's it's a really
good breakdown of what happened with us
in terms of what Russia did and what you
effectively have here is that within
particular Facebook and the Cambridge
analytical scandal where you had this
company that essentially started
plotting all these data points very one
day I don't wanna call the equivalent
but they effectively did a genome
mapping of all of our preferences and
data points and that weaponized the data
that you're talking about this is what
happened so now they know hey Neal is
very disposed to wanting to talk about
this and talking about that and you know
we call them trolls farms where there
are these these kind of fake accounts
that are designed to seem like real
people and start inflaming people and
getting them into conversations and then
all of a sudden you have a polarized
nation so you you you effectively
because you know the United States is
Titan right and so kind of like the
Avengers in that point right like you
don't beat us from the outside right you
take home what was that movie a civil
war well yeah the guy was like no no
we're gonna I love you please stop
trying to hurt us okay
sorry I'm wait so Heather I this sounds
like something you guys never thought
could or would happen the size you knew
that we would have hot buttons as human
beings but to have that weaponized put
against us to pit us against each other
I mean it's psychological warfare and
it's just basically the brain is an
information processing machine so you
can manipulate people by manipulating
the information that they are accessed
right you knew you could do that one on
one but you know you can do that for an
entire society oh yeah yeah no we've
always had the tools to do it so let's
let's be clear they're better yeah
they're much better and more effective
but the truth of the matter is what
happened with what you said Cambridge
analytic and Facebook and the
weaponization of information is
something that they that the military
calls psyops
that's exactly what it is so why I don't
understand why people don't say what
things are
that is called psyops it is forbidden
because it is that effective so you know
so what kind of policy changes do we
need to put into play to protect us
going forward without completely
constraining our freedoms yeah I mean a
little a lot what would work in helping
with data protections European Union is
a little stronger a lot stronger than we
are on that so it would help if our data
was treated like the commodity that it
is what does that entail I don't know
what you mean when you access access to
your personal information but not only
that I mean also like just restrictions
on disinformation I mean you know I was
talking to an executive Facebook who
actually left Facebook because they're
not putting restrictions on
disinformation and political ads and
that's that's really dangerous so I
think there are places where we can in
the sort of private sector you know or
at least let there be policies in place
so that you know nonsense isn't getting
out there at least in the political
realm which influences how we vote in
the media they have to be the watchdog's
are supposed to be not lapdogs not
saying watchdogs not lapdog because you
can't just say oh the administration
said this and that's it like your job is
to question right and so the public
trusts the media to give that
information we've seen very recently
that has not always been the case and
Heather so we're being manipulated
without even knowing it yes that's the
insidious thing most of us think we're
making decisions of our own free will
but we're really doing things because
we're being unconsciously manipulated
all the time that's because we're all in
a simulation and someone else's
programming our behavior how sweet we
got we got in there well you haven't we
got to do another tour around so we got
to end it there Heather thanks for
coming as usual Chuck a my man always
good all right this has been star talk
and I've been your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson as always
[Music]